[Music]
these were the two laws of refraction of
light we saw in a previous video the
Snell's law tells us that this ratio is
constant and is equal to the refractive
index of medium 2 with respect to medium
1 and it is also equal to the ratio of
speed of light in medium 1 to the speed
of light in medium 2 and that is the
same as the ratio of the absolute
refractive index of medium 2 to the
absolute refractive index of medium 1
let's try to solve a simple example
based on this here is the question on
your screen go through it carefully we
are given the refractive index of glass
with respect to air as 1.50
here air is the incident medium and
glass is the refractive medium let us
take medium one as air and medium two as
glass so n - 1 is equal to one point
five zero but what is n - 1 equal to yes
it's equal to speed of light in medium 1
over the speed of light in medium 2 here
V 1 is speed of light in air and V 2 is
a speed of light in glass but we aren't
given any of the two values we want to
find out the speed of light in glass and
for that we need the speed of light in
air we can write V 2 as V 1 over 1.5 the
value of speed of light in air is very
close to the value of speed of light in
vacuum hence we can substitute this
value in place of speed of light in air
after doing a bit of math we will get
the speed of light in glass as 2 times
10 to the power 8 meters per second
don't forget the unit's we see that the
speed of light in glass is lesser in the
next video we will talk about an
important optical device which is very
widely used
[Music]